welcome to ottawa thank you for being
here
welcome
you're in the right place
you're doing the right thing
welcome to ottawa
please be gentle with the police they
are our brothers whatever they're doing
is not right we stand our grounds
we're not leaving
and uh we're doing everything peaceful
and
with love and smile they have no grounds
so when they come in here which they
will
uh-huh what's your plan my plan
i'm i park legally this is federal land
i i have my rights to protest peacefully
which i'm doing
and they have no rights and if they
violate my law
we're gonna see in the court if they
come and tell you leave because it's
finished then what finish what
finish fighting for freedom
no i decide when it's
finished fight when i know all the
mandates are
lifted right so this is the main point
we came here to have all the maintenance
listed uh release that law about border
checkers
right so we can go back to work
without that i'm not working so might as
well stay here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
peace
[Music]
you're ready for it
yourself in the mirror
[Applause]
hey
we're touching us we're not touching you
we are okay
that's not gonna be good enough
all right
oh
[Music]
16 year old
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
communism
[Applause]
we love you in the name of jesus christ
and we love your souls
oh